- I hired a opposition
research company
to go in and pull the
voter registration records
of the White House press corps.
These are public records,
anybody can do it.
And they discovered that
by a ratio of 12 to one,
the seats of the White House
are occupied by
registered Democrats.
(soft upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a former White
House press secretary,
a Fox News contributor and
author of the new book,
I've got in my hand right now,
"Suppression, Deception,
Snobbery, and Bias:
"Why the Press Gets So Much
Wrong and Just Doesn't Care.
Ari Fleischer, welcome
to the "Rubin Report".
- Dave, thank you for having me.
- Ari, I feel like you wrote
this book for me personally
because this basically gets
to the heart of everything
that I do every hour that I
spend working on this show
that the media is sort
of a bigger problem
than almost anything
else at the moment.
But before we dive
into the book,
you have a really interesting
backstory and all that stuff.
How do you get
involved in politics?
What eventually got
you to the White House
and then we'll get
into all this stuff?
- Well, to put it in a nutshell,
it was totally an accident.
I graduated from college.
I moved home to play
baseball and a friend of mine
had a brother who was
managing a congressional race.
They needed a press secretary.
I knew nothing and I got
the job which tells you
how little you need to know
to be a press secretary.
And I fell in love
with politics.
We lost, it was 1982.
Reagan stayed the course.
Only one Republican
challenger won that cycle
but I got the bug, I
moved to Washington.
I was unemployed and I got
a job as a press secretary
to a New York congressman and
that began a 16 year career
on Capitol Hill followed
by the Bush campaign
where I moved to Texas in
1999 and then The White House.
- Do you miss being in the
thick of the political madness?
- No.
- Nothing?
Is there nothing
you miss about it?
- I spent 21 wonderful
years in Washington
and I loved every one
of the days I was there
and especially at
The White House
and when I was
communications director
of the Ways and Means Committee
after Republican took
control of the house,
tremendous excitement
and satisfaction
but I was never a
Washington for life type.
So one day you just
know, your day has come,
it's time to go.
And it hit me after
21 long years.
So I loved it, I loved
standing at that podium Dave,
at The White House,
I loved taking heat.
I loved catching the curve
balls, the fast balls
and standing my ground
on behalf of a president
and a person who I
really believe in.
And that's what it's about.
If you believe deeply,
Washington is the town to
be in and then go back home.
- Believe it or not, I
watched many, many, many
of those press conferences
that you were doing back then.
They were sort of must see TV
and this will sort of segue us
a little bit bit to the book,
Correct me if I'm
wrong, the media treats
Republican press secretaries
and Republican administrations
a little bit different than
Democrat press secretaries
and administrations,
is that fair to say?
- Yeah, I just caught
friendly softballs
from The White
House press corps,
you know they loved
conservatives, they loved Bush.
Look, the truth is as much
as things have changed
since I was press
secretary 20 years ago
and they have changed a lot,
they've gotten a lot
worse and nastier,
fact is right now, Peter
Doocy from Fox News,
the only one of those 49
seats asking hard questions
to the Biden press secretary.
When I was press secretary,
there were 49 seats
asking me hard questions.
That's the problem,
the press takes sides
and they did back then.
But back then, David,
it was more just your
liberal conservative bias
reporters still thought their
job at the end of the day
was be objective and
tell the news fair
and not give their
opinions on the air.
Today you watch CNN, you
watch almost every show
and they think their
job is to give opinions
and that's what they do and
it's killing journalism.
- So when do you
think that started?
Because I think anyone
watching this, they get it.
That's what I spend most of
my show doing at this point
is debunking a lot
of the nonsense that
CNN, New York Times,
Washington Post, that
they're putting out as fact,
when if you just
read the headline
with a little more
precision, you will see
that it actually is opinion.
- Yeah, absolutely right.
Look, it started
because of two reasons.
One is technology.
The internet led to the
decline of advertising
for print newspapers and it
changed how you can watch
the news as we had a
proliferation of outlets.
So you had conservatives
watching conservative media,
you had liberals
watching liberal media
and newspapers
had no more money.
The only way they got money
was from their subscribers.
And so, they didn't wanna
alienate their subscribers.
Unlike an advertiser, who
wanted you to appeal broadly
to the entire country
so you had to be mindful
of staying somewhat
sensible and accurate,
now you could let it rip.
And then along came
more social media,
Twitter and other places
where reporters felt
really good given
their opinions.
They didn't value
objectivity anymore,
they wanted them more
Twitter followers.
They wanted the praise of
Hollywood actors and actresses
when they let their opinion rip.
Hence Jim Acosta at CNN,
John Harwood at CNN,
daytime reporters who
don't report, they opine
and always from a far
left point of view,
anti-Trump, anti-Republican.
And then the other
factor was Trump.
When Trump emerged, the press
somehow made the decision
to save the republic.
They decided that the
American people erred in 2016
by not electing Hillary
and the press was
gonna fix the mistake.
So these snobs put
themselves in the position
superior to the people and said,
collusion is probably
how come Trump won.
The Steele dossier is credible.
And we're gonna put
Trump and the country
through years of misery to
make the case against him.
And as I write in the book,
they didn't put just
their finger on the scale,
they put their writing
hand on the scale
and many of 'em put their
entire bodies on the scale.
And this is the
mainstream media today.
And that's why I
wrote the book, David,
this is why I blew the
whistle on the press.
I try to be fair.
I will always call
the balls and strikes.
I supported President
Trump on policy
pretty much all the time.
I regularly tweeted that I
objected to his behavior.
When he tweeted something
I thought went too far
and was offensive,
I called him on it.
But when I saw the
coverage of Donald Trump,
how biased, unfair, get Trump.
If it was anti-Trump,
it got a bump coverage.
I said, I'm gonna
write about this.
It's not good for the country.
It's not good for democracy.
It's not good for journalism
when reporters are in the tank.
- Do you think that they
would've done the same thing
to your guy, George W. Bush,
had social media been
as big back then?
'Cause I remember very
specifically one day,
I used to live on the upper west
which is bastion of
liberalism, Columbia AU.
And I remember during
the Bush presidency
and it was during the Iraq war
when the media was
going crazy all the time
and you were doing the press
junkets and all that stuff.
I remember walking out and
there was a guy with a table
with books and I remember
every single book
basically was George
W. Bush is the devil
like every single book.
And they were all
being bought of course.
And had social media
existed at the time,
my guess is they would've
done the exact same thing.
It just would've
happened earlier.
- Yeah, I know you're
right about that.
And I think one of the
points I make in the book
is regardless of what
President Trump decides to do
whether he runs or doesn't run,
they're gonna do
it to Ron DeSantis.
They're gonna do
it to Kristi Noem.
They're gonna do it to
Ted Cruz or Tom Cotton.
And here's where I have some
sympathy for President Trump.
What he will tell you
is Republicans don't
fight hard enough
and that's why he
does what he does.
And I think there's some merit
to that because he recognized
the mainstream media is in the
tank, they're out to get 'em,
they're not fair,
they're not objective.
And so it made him fight twice
as hard, three times as hard.
I wish sometimes he
had just gotten it
with a little more
subtlety or nuance
but that's not his nature.
He let it rip
everywhere he went.
He was a bull in a China shop
and he took a new China shop
with him everywhere he went.
And so, it's a calibration
issue but yeah,
Republicans and
conservatives need to fight
because my conclusion
writing this book
is that the media has
turned to activists.
The mainstream media and by
that I mean the New York Times,
The Washington Post,
ABC, NBC, CBS, CNN,
they are activists for a cause
and it's a liberal cause.
My first chapter is
called original sin
and I go into how many
reporters are Democrats?
I hired a opposition
research company
to go in and pull the
voter registration records
of The White House Press Corp.
These are public records,
anybody can do it.
And they discovered that
by a ratio of 12 to one,
the seats of The White
House are occupied
by registered Democrats.
Now, Dave, why
isn't it one to one?
Or why isn't it 12 to one
Republican to Democrat?
The news would be different
if it was 12 to one
Republican to Democrat.
But The White House press corp,
journalism schools
throughout America,
newsrooms pretty much
but especially in
Washington and New York
overwhelmingly cut
from the same cloth.
Think alike, act alike, dress
alike, tweet alike Democrats.
And there's another
study I found in here.
It's a Pew Research study.
The only group of
Americans who say
the press understands them are
college educated Democrats.
If you're a Democrat-
- You don't say?
- You say the press
doesn't understand me.
Independents,
regardless of degree,
press doesn't understand me
and certainly all
Republicans say that.
The press is dug itself
into a cul-de-sac.
They are college educated
Democrats who know how to write
and think only for fellow
college educated Democrats.
And if you own a gun,
if your grandfather
taught you how to hunt,
if you think life
begins a conception,
if you pray every day, the
press doesn't understand you.
And that's a huge
problem with journalism.
- Do you think that they
know that they're biased?
I mean, I think you're right
when you said the
Twitter thing before.
Twitter sort of unasked it
because then every minute
of every day they were
sharing their opinions
and then over time, you
could aggregate it and go,
okay, you guys obviously
have a certain point of view
but I look at a guy like,
you know I hit CNN all
the time on my show.
Jake Tapper is always thought
of as the one non-insane guy
there but it's obvious
he's a Democrat.
Like do you think that they
know what they're doing
or do you think they
honestly believe
they're pulling the
wool over our eyes?
- They know it and I've
talked to 'em about it.
They know it, a lot of 'em
privately acknowledge it
but they won't do
anything about it.
And this is the problem 'cause
they're too like-minded.
They're in denial and
they're in decline.
They're watching their
viewership go down,
they're watching
their ratings go down.
They're watching the trust from
the American people go down.
But unlike any
corporation who would say
when they have a trend like
that, what's wrong with us?
What do we need
to do differently?
Reporters tend to say,
what's wrong with America?
What do the Americans
need to do differently?
- So what do we do about that?
What do we do about that?
I mean, is it that
basically the new guy at CNN
just has to fire everybody.
I mean, is it as simple as that?
Does it even matter anymore?
I mean, should any of us care?
We know that the
ratings are going down.
Should we just let them die?
Let them just go extinct?
- No and here's where I think,
and I hope my book is
a little bit different.
I point these things out
because I lament them.
I want the press to be fair,
I want them to be objective.
It's so good for America
if we can pick up
one source of news and say,
yep, I believe it, I trust it.
Now here's what I think
needs to be done about it
without the media telling us
what we're supposed to think.
My solution to it is number
one, young people conservatives
need to get into
journalism, it's healthy.
Number two, journalism schools,
newsrooms need to actively
recruit people who
think differently.
Journalism needs a booster
shot of independent thought
and that's not gonna come
from the same old people.
It will come from more
conservative thinking people.
So if I'm a journalism school,
if I'm a Columbia
School of Journalism,
when I interview
somebody, I would say,
tell me what your habits are,
what are your favorite hobbies?
And if somebody says, I like
to hunt, I like to fish,
I enjoy going to church.
To me, that is a sign
of ideological diversity
that I want in my newsroom.
These people are so hung up on
sexual orientation or gender
or race as opposed to the
most powerful diversity of all
which is diversity of the
mind, the way you think.
So that's number one, journalism
schools need to change.
Conservatives need
to go into J school.
And then newsrooms, and this
is where the CNN experiment
is gonna be fascinating.
The new leadership of CNN
says they wanna return
to objectivity, I'm
gonna watch them.
I wanna see what
they do, we'll see.
- So on the first
point on the schools,
I mean, I agree with you but
do you think there's honestly
any chance in high hell that
anyone at Columbia University
that's been completely
infected by this woke thing
is gonna do it?
I mean, do you think any
professor of journalism
is gonna put their
butt on the line
to do what you just
said right there?
- Yeah, probably not.
And again, I lament it
but that's the solution
'cause what's the alternative?
The alternative as we
continue the trend we're on,
Now here's what that
trend looks like.
Conservative media is booming.
Conservative viewership
continues to go up.
Liberal media, it goes down
but it's not healthy
for democracy.
Again, I want to be able to
pick up one source of news
and say, I'm done for the
day, it took me 10 minutes.
I read it, I accept it, and
here's what we need to do now.
And then you debate it
in the political sphere
and you actually go to
vote and whoever wins,
wins the election and
moves the country.
But we shouldn't have to as
a people read five sources
of news to figure out what
is right and what is wrong
and weigh it and balance it.
And I get that
question all the time.
Where can I go?
And frankly, I'll tell
you this too, Dave,
the best show on the
news in my opinion
is the six o'clock evening
show on Fox with Bret Baier.
It is old fashioned,
straight down the middle,
good reporting.
It's not cut from the same
liberal cloth but it's not
ideological conservative
show either.
It's just straight
reporting and I miss that,
I like watching that show.
- So speaking of Fox since
you're a Fox contributor
and I go on Fox a
couple times a week.
I find Fox, they never
tell me what to say,
I say whatever I want, often
things that are against say
the general conservative line.
I'm guessing that they let
you say whatever you want
but feel free to
correct that if not.
But there's a constant
move to take them out.
I mean, there is a
constant move to make sure
that Tucker who is the
number one cable news host
in the history of television
cannot get advertisers.
How does all that fit into the
situation we're in right now?
- Remember where that started?
Remember when Barack Obama
tried to take out Rush Limbaugh?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- He went after Rush by name.
It was a deliberate White
House effort to take down Rush.
And then they tried
to do it to Fox.
And this is why I kind of do
doubt that the mainstream media
is capable of fixing itself.
They lost their customers.
The only reason Fox found a
home was because people voted
to leave the liberal
mainstream media
'cause they were no
longer being served.
They recognized how
liberal the media became.
And it it's kinda like
China with Taiwan.
The mainstream media
does not like the fact
that there's a breakaway.
That there's one group
that thinks independently,
that thinks differently,
that recognizes that the ways
of the liberal mainstream media
are not the ways
of most Americans.
And so they need
to take down Fox
just like China wants
to re-absorb Taiwan.
And again, look at the ratings.
The American people
have rejected what
the mainstream media
is doing, that's why
Fox is so popular.
They struck a niche.
They found a home with the
independent different thought
and it can't be stopped.
But Fox is really alone.
You have Fox, you do have a
talk radio, you do a podcast,
you do have now have a new
type of electronic front,
The Federalist, "The
Daily Examiner",
things of that nature,
The Daily Wire.
But again, it's the
balkanization of
American information
and I read left right
and center but man,
I have to work hard
to figure things out.
Again, I think it'd be easier
for the American people
if we had faith in one
as opposed to have
this balkanization.
- How much of this do
you think is connected
to sort of the progressive
takeover of the Democrat Party
that say when you were press
secretary and as you said,
there was a little more of a
blend of reporters in there.
Okay, the answer is different
but we can basically agree
on the facts that now
basically the modern left,
the Democrat Party, they
don't believe America
is fundamentally decent.
They don't seem to believe
in our founding documents
or separation of powers,
all of these things.
So that of course is then
gonna leak into the people
who are translating the
news to the average guy.
- And it's even
worse than that, Dave
because you have a young
generation of reporters
who think their job is to
be subjective not objective.
They think there's something
wrong with objectivity.
There was a study that
came out just last week.
It was a Pew study of
journalists and it reported
that the majority of
journalists don't believe
in telling two sides
of the news anymore.
That they view one
side as misinformation,
it shouldn't be told.
Well, whose opinion is
it if it's information
or misinformation?
And it said that news outlets
whose audiences lean left,
by two to one, don't think they
should be telling both sides
of a story.
And then it surveyed journalists
who worked at news outlets
whose audience leans
right and by them, 60/40,
it was said that you should
cover two sides of the story.
So who's being fair?
Who is being objective?
And who is being lopsided?
And it's the takeover
of journalism
by these young social warriors,
which is what they are,
is killing journalism and it
happened at the New York Times.
One of my favorite parts of
the book is what happened
when Senator Tom Cotton
wrote op-ed online
for the New York Times that
the New York Times headlined
Send in the Troops.
And it was in the summer of 2020
after the George Floyd murder
and riots were everywhere.
150 federal buildings
were damaged.
And Tom Cotton said
Send in the Troops.
A meltdown in the New
York Times newsroom.
Young reporters, one after
another after another tweeted
that this was violence to them.
The violence was in the streets.
The violence was
with the poor people
who ran mom and pop shops
that were being torn down
and looted and destroyed.
But it was these people sitting
in a cubicle in Manhattan
who said, this is
violence and they forced
The New York Times to tuck its
tail, to retract the op-ed,
to say it never should have
been run in the first place,
to fire their
editorial page editor,
reassign the deputy
editorial page editor.
It was a purge.
It was like a college
campus broke out
inside The New York Times
where the young people
demanded the administration
silence of voice
with which they disagree.
It was one of the worst,
most embarrassing episodes
to be a media organization
dedicated to free speech.
But free speech
didn't stand a chance
against the young social
warriors of journalism.
- Yeah and that's also
why for me personally,
to me these things
have been infected.
I don't think CNN can come back.
When I give talks at college
campuses, if I say CNN,
I used to say CNN and
then I would make a joke.
Now if I just say
CNN, they laugh.
CNN is already to the punchline
just saying those three letters
is already the punchline.
So something like
The New York times,
I mean, Barry Weiss
is not liberal enough
for the New York Times.
They got a real
problem on their hands.
- Exactly right and
all newsrooms do
because I interviewed
one journalism professor
at the Cronkite School in
Arizona and she was telling me
that many of her students
really do heartedly believe
that the reason you
go into journalism
is to bring your point
of view to the people
as opposed to bring facts
and the truth to the people
and let the people tell you
what their point of view is.
And Dave, that's the
fundamental point.
Newspapers have analyses,
newspapers have commentary.
If it's on the editorial page,
if it's on the nightly part
of the Fox News hour with
Sean Hannity or with Tucker
or with Don Lemon at CNN,
that's opinion and we get it.
But when the news itself
is twisted to represent
a point of view, we
have a real problem.
And that's been the case for
decades at The New York Times.
And infection is a good
word, it's infected,
the mainstream media
all over the place.
That's why I keep blowing a
whistle throughout this book.
You know, one of the
favorite things I do in here
is I put pictures up of
how The New York Times
covered the exact same thing.
So when Ruth Bader
Ginsburg passed away,
front page headline, this
was The Washington Post,
but the front page headline
was Pioneer for Equality Dies.
When Antonin Scalia passed
away, the same headline,
Washington Post, banner
headline was something along
the lines of the Champion
of Liberal Taunting Dies.
Something along those lines.
One was a pioneer for rights,
the other taunted the left,
how is this fair?
How is this neutral?
How is it objective?
But it's a point of view and
it's in the papers every day.
- Does that also explain why
we sort of seemingly have like
a mass mental health
problem right now
that so many people have
bought into this framework
that is dishonest and it doesn't
connect with what they see
in real life but it's
constantly pushed on them,
so everyone starts feeling
crazy about politics?
- One of the other points
I really make in here
that I think is different is
we all know what it's like
to be a conservative and
have them look down on us
and treat us with
disdain for our habits
or views or traditions.
But the group that I also argue
is really hurt are liberals.
Because if everything you
see, if everything you're told
and if all the people you're
surrounded with say to you,
Hillary's going to win.
It's going to be a landslide,
of course she's gonna win.
Trump has zero chance.
And then Trump wins.
You either have to say,
how come you misinform me
which they don't do?
Or how did Trump do it?
It had to be another reason,
it had to be collusion.
So you then are susceptible
to people giving you
the misinformation
that Trump colluded.
And then when you hear
Mueller is investigating
and you watch MSNBC,
you're told every night,
the walls are closing
in, another shoe dropped.
More questions than answers
and you reach the conclusion,
Trump's on his way out.
You do it now with the
January 6th Committee.
Trump's gonna get
indicted, isn't he?
These people keep fooling
themselves into going down
a criminal cul-de-sac that
says the people I don't like
in politics are criminals
and somebody's about
to get rid of them.
And when it doesn't happen,
you can't understand it
'cause everybody thinks
the same way you do.
And I do think that
contributes to this feeling
that people have of
bitterness, of animosity,
of mental breakdowns
in some cases
because what they were told to
expect doesn't match reality.
And that's the problem
with the liberal media,
it's hurting the liberal
base of our country too.
- So I think most
people watching this
get sort of the young
journalist, quote
unquote journalist,
I always have to put air
quotes with journalists
but the young kid part
of it that they come in
and infect these things.
But what do you think
at the corporate level?
Because when we show
clips of MSNBC on my show
which we do a
couple times a week,
I call it the televised
mental institution of MSNBC
because you would
not be able to tell
that it was not broadcasting
from a mental institution.
When you listen to some
of the crazy things
that Joy Reid is saying.
I mean, it genuinely, it
seems psychotic to me,
that would be my
prescription on that.
But what do you think
is happening at the
corporate level?
Like I get at the
newsroom level,
okay, maybe they've been all
infected but this is MSNBC,
Microsoft NBC, these are
massive corporate powers
that they're
watching this going,
they know this can't be true,
that this nonsense is not
true that they're spewing.
- As long as it appeals to
a significant enough niche,
they can make enough money
on advertising revenue
and subscribers,
that's all they need.
And so they've given up the
notion of serving the country,
serving all the people, they
just need to serve their niche.
And if their niche wants to
hear that Trump colluded,
if their niche
wants to hear that
Stacey Abrams actual
election was stolen,
that's what they'll
tell their niche.
So again, this is technology.
You know, in the older days,
when you didn't really have
all these niches that
were so easily available
to be found on the internet,
you had to tell the news in
a broader, more fair sense.
They don't have to do that
anymore so that's again,
reason for pessimism.
But here's how these
things ultimately do fix.
You know one of the
reasons a Hispanic vote
is increasingly
voting Republican
is because of all this
woke stuff, all this.
You know, men can have babies?
If you had any bit
of traditional in
you, you'll just say,
who are these people?
I can't be part
of this thinking.
And Hispanics are increasingly
turning Republican.
I think one of the solutions
here is the Democrats
start to lose their
base of support
and increasingly just remain,
in MSNBC, just remains
the tellers of tales for upper
income, liberal white people
and they've lost working
class blue collar people.
They've started to
lose Hispanic voters
and if they start to
lose African Americans
more than they already are,
that's when they're
gonna start to realize
this upper middle
income white niche,
the upper west side
isn't big enough.
We need to change,
that's when it'll happen.
- So since I have no doubt you
know basically everyone in DC
although maybe some of them
won't talk to you publicly like,
do you talk to any Democrats,
old school Democrats,
say guys that were across the
aisle from you 20 years ago
when you were in the
administration that are going,
we just lost control of this
thing like that the train
is just completely
outta control.
We don't know how to
stop what's going on
with the Democrats right now.
- Yeah, I think there's
a growing sense of that.
And it takes elections,
it really takes
when a group that you
always had in your corner
like the Hispanic vote
does start to break 50/50.
These are the things
that shock politicians
into changing their behavior.
Now I think Joe Manchin is
on the front edge of that
for the Democratic Party.
Kyrsten Sinema, interestingly
as well, Senator from Arizona.
It's the Bernie Sanders,
the Elizabeth Warrens
that are killing the party.
And you'll notice
it's the appeal
to the upper income,
white liberal.
And that's just the
wrong group to create
any type of national
consensus from.
And one of the great things
about American politics
is we have to create broad
coalitions to govern.
We're not like Europe, we
don't have six major parties
in our parliaments
each of which splits
and then you have to
play coalition politics.
We have two big parties and
if two big parties can create
internal coalitions,
they can govern America.
If Democrats are on
their way to proving,
they're proving it under by them
that they can't govern America.
- So I wanna get a
little more into that
but going a bit more
on the media side,
you've mentioned this
balkanization a couple of times
and that there's a danger there.
Do you think in some ways that
there's also a
silver lining to it
which is that the more
that we get balkanized,
whether it's geographically,
as you know I moved
from Cali to Florida.
Or through the
information that we get,
that people are really thinking
about what they believe,
that they are
actually putting it,
some of this stuff
into practice,
whether it's by moving
or finding sources
that make sense to them and
ignoring some of the old stuff
and that we just are
in a transition phase.
It just is and there
are more choices now.
- Yeah and the fact is
the pendulum always swings
in the United States and
it goes in one direction
for a while and goes
back in another direction
and it never swings that far.
And that's one of the great
strengths of our country.
So I think there's
something to that
and I also look at the
history of journalism.
We're back to the way
we were on 1776 or 1789
when pamphlets really
represented news.
And my side put out a pamphlet,
the other side put
out a pamphlet.
It was all advocacy.
This notion of objective
reporting is a relatively
newfound notion that began
the early to middle on
part of the 20th century.
Prior to that, you really
had yellow journalism,
the Hearsts and scare
everybody as much as you can
and sell the paper for
a penny every afternoon.
So things do swing and
change but eventually
people get fed up and things
go back to what is sensible.
And that's why I'm hoping
it'll return to what sensible,
that's why I wrote the book.
It's why I have my
recommendations in there
for how to change newsrooms
and journalism schools.
And if it doesn't happen in the
next five years or 10 years,
I think it's still going to
happen because eventually
that pendulum always heads
back to the sensible direction.
- So a lot of people always
ask me, was it always this bad?
And I try to think
back, I'm I'm 46.
I remember the nightly
news on ABC, CBS, NBC
and it was basically
whether you liked Broca
or Peter Jennings or what's
his name? Dan Rather.
But that the structure of the
show and what they covered
was basically the same.
Maybe the order was a
little bit different
but they pretty much
recovering the same things
or Walter Cronkite before that.
Do you think there was too
much protection over topics
that maybe they weren't
talking about back then?
- Well, protection over topics,
what I would say is there
was too much of a one sided
nature of storytelling.
How often would you see on
the news about a good guy
with a gun stopping a bad
guy with a gun in a killing?
Because you need gun control.
So if a citizen who had a
concealed carry stopped a crime,
they didn't tell you about
that because that would've made
the case for concealed carry.
The trial of Kermit Gosnell
which I talk about in my book,
probably the greatest serial
killer in American history,
an abortion doctor who delivered
thousands upon
thousands of babies.
He sniffed the spinal cords
of babies about to be born,
late term abortionist.
And his trial was suppressed.
It was hardly any
news coverage of it.
America's greatest
serial killer, why?
Because if the network
went wall to wall
with coverage of that trial,
it actually made people
think twice about being
pro-life or pro-choice.
And in a newsroom, that's
yucky to have people
who think pro-life
be legitimized.
Nobody thinks like
that inside a newsroom.
So there was an absence
of coverage and again,
this is what gave
way to Fox News.
Fox said, you're only
telling one side of a story,
you're leaving on the
cutting room floor
so much of American life.
So that's what was wrong
with the three networks
back in their heyday.
You know, when
Reagan was president
some 50 or 60 million
Americans watched ABC, NBC, CBS
at 6:30 Eastern in the evening
and now only 20 million do.
I mean, 30 to 35
million went elsewhere.
They went to Fox
and they went to
the diversification
of other outlets.
- So when you were
press secretary
and there was a little
more honesty there,
now when you watch and
it's so outta control
and you mention Peter Doocy,
we show a lot of clips
to him on the show
but it's not just that the
press themselves are worse,
it seems like the
press secretaries have
gotten much worse.
Let's say the last
two specifically.
That Psaki, I mean,
the woman simply,
I don't think could
say a true statement.
My line on her was always,
if you asked her what
her favorite color was,
she would say four.
I mean, she just couldn't
say anything true.
And now you got this
Karine Jean-Pierre
who actually seems worse.
I mean, completely unqualified.
Am I overstating
it with these two?
Am I not giving enough credit
to how difficult the job is?
- Well, let me put it this way.
And here I am old school,
the job is hard enough
and I will not make fun
or take on a fellow,
a press secretary.
I don't think it's
fitting for me to do that.
I understand people
make the criticisms,
I won't be one of those
people doing it by name.
I just will say their problem
is not a communications problem.
Their problem is a Joe
Biden judgment decision
policy problem, old age problem.
They have a lot of other things
that they have to deal with.
Other people can take on
their communication skills.
- Okay, so putting aside the
specifics of the two of them,
generally, as far as the
administration right now,
it seems like so
many things are wrong
and you just mentioned that
the media doesn't cover
certain things.
Finally, it looks like
in the last two weeks,
there are suddenly discussions
about what's going on
with Biden cognitively
and is he up to the job
and it's even
leaking into CNN now.
A whole bunch of us
were talking about it
before the election but is
that another piece of this
that they just
airlock certain things
and then we can all see it.
We all know
something's not right,
he can't read off
the prompter anymore.
The rambling, the incoherent
nonsense, now where am I,
who's in charge,
all of this stuff
but now it's finally leaking
which means that eventually
it will fully get
through the airlock.
- Yeah and not only those
stories which appeared
in The New York Times and
the poll of Democrats saying
they don't want Biden to
run which The New York Times
made that lead story
on the front page.
Look at the Time's this
coverage of Biden's trip
to Saudi Arabia, it was
brutal for Joe Biden.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- It's as if a flip has
switched in The New York Times
where they've made the
judgment that it's time
for a younger, different
Democrat to take Biden down,
that we don't want Biden
to run for re-election.
You almost get that sense that
they have a editorial change
in terms of the headlines
on the front page.
Now I'll predict to you,
Dave, it's a passing stage.
They'll do this until
it doesn't work.
And then if Biden
declares for re-election,
all of a sudden, The New
York Times is gonna say,
look at the vigor he's
got as an 82 year old man,
look at how strong he is.
And especially if the
opponent is Donald Trump,
they'll flip right back
to their current mode.
But it is something
to watch right now
'cause it is interesting.
They're giving Biden
a tough time recently.
I'd say to you also, the
press was ridiculously easy
on Biden throughout
the entire campaign.
They had their whole
body on the scale
because they wanted
Trump to be defeated.
They suppressed stories
that would've hurt Biden.
His failure to read
off the teleprompter.
You know, one of the
examples I have in my book is
he did a campaign
event for the AFL CIO,
a young woman said to him,
threw him a softball and said,
"Well, how do you get more
people to join a union?"
And his answer, this is
all on TV on a Biden video.
His answer was, "Ah, ah,
ah, move it up there."
And then he gave the answer.
The Q&A preloaded
on a teleprompter.
And until they put the
teleprompter and made it run,
he didn't know the answer to
how do you get more people
to join a union.
What would a normal
press corp have done?
They'd a pounded the guy.
He's about to become
possibly the oldest president
in the United States
history if he wins.
He can't even answer
a question like that,
did he have a teleprompter?
How did he get the
answer written there
if he didn't get
the Q ahead of time?
Do you have people providing
you with friendly audiences,
giving you questions
ahead of time?
Everything was all
the ingredients for
a feeding frenzy.
- If you were part of the
administration, would you be,
I mean, I know they've
tried to hide him.
He doesn't really do
long form interviews.
He always gets the notes with
who he's allowed to call on
and then if he rambles too long,
he says that he's in trouble.
Like none of it makes any
sense or is optically positive
or any of that.
But if you were press secretary
or you were the
administration right now
and you saw what was going
on, What would you be advising
the president to
do at this point?
- It's beyond advice there.
Frankly, there's little to
nothing they can do anymore
because it's about policy.
It's about what's
happened to the country.
It's about inflation, the cost
of living, the cost of gas,
energy, heating your home,
air conditioning your home,
buying food, buying coffee,
the Southern border crime.
I mean, can you name
more tangible things
that are hurting the country?
You know, it's not
like social security
is gonna go bankrupt
in seven years
or the Medicare trust fund is
gonna go bankrupt in eight,
it's not these big
amorphous things.
It's the daily things
you feel in life.
Am I gonna get
mugged walking home?
Can I afford the things I
need to buy to feed my family?
This is what's happening
to our country right now
as a particularly
hidden lower income
and middle income people.
So it's beyond a speech, it's
beyond advice, it's events
and the public gets it,
the country gets it.
The only thing I could
suggest for Joe Biden
if he really wants to change
is he should start going
after liberal prosecutors
out the country.
He should support the recall
of LA's district attorney.
If he started to
send a different note
that he actually
is in the 1990s,
Joe Biden who wants to
protect people's lives
and get tough on crime, that
could have a different impact.
Biden might be seen
differently if he did that.
There's very little
else he could do.
- Well, actually to that point,
I mean, does this guy, Biden
strike you as someone very
different than you knew of
say 20 years ago?
I mean, it's almost like he's
sort of the perfect candidate
for the left because
he doesn't know
what he believes anymore.
He reads anything and he's just
ushering in the destruction
that I personally,
I think that the more
radical people want.
I don't think he wants
to destroy the country,
I just don't think he knows
what he's doing at this point.
- Look, I've known Joe
Biden for many decades.
I used to work for
a different senator,
Pete Demenici of New Mexico.
I got to know Joe Biden.
And then I knew him when
I was at The White House.
And I always knew Joe
Biden was a blow heart,
he was just a talker and
he didn't have much depth.
He didn't have much substance.
As Robert Gates, the
former secretary of defense
to George Bush and
Barack Obama said
about every foreign policy
decision over the last 30 years,
Joe Biden has gotten wrong.
And now that's spread to
domestic decisions too.
I mean, one of the biggest
reasons we have inflation
is 'cause Biden insist
on that massive blowout
government spending
redistribution package
when he first got elected that
he was able to jam through
on a party line vote.
And he doesn't think that
contributed to inflation?
Biden just has
terrible judgment.
Now he just wants
to spend more money
and he really has not
shown the spine to stand up
to the woke left.
He's really become Bernie
Sanders running mate
as opposed to the
nation's leader.
- Yeah, I just don't think
he has the cognitive ability
to do it.
I think if he did, then
maybe he would be a little,
maybe he'd still be a blow heart
but maybe would be pushing
back, I just don't think he can.
But it's interesting 'cause
you said the thing about that,
it's not really about
messaging, it's about policy.
But it's like the messaging
has just been
absolutely terrible.
I mean, on any given day
you can get him saying,
hey, this is Putin's price hike
and then the same day you
can get his energy secretary
or transportation
secretary saying, no,
this is because we're going
through an energy transition
and this is a once in
a lifetime opportunity.
So it's not just,
I mean, it's not just
the policies, the
messaging has made,
no, we're not gonna
have inflation.
Inflation's transitory.
I hope there's no inflation.
Like it's all of it, kind of.
- I'm not gonna meet with
the Saudi Crown Prince.
I met with the
Saudi Crown Prince.
His feeling this
about a fist bump
as opposed to a handshake.
No, I imagine leaders around
the world are laughing
at Joe Biden saying
he's so weak,
he has to pretend he can't
even shake a man's hand.
If you're gonna go, go.
If you're not
gonna go, don't go.
But don't be right in the
middle, have it both ways.
And that's, Biden's just weak.
I think that's a
bigger part of it.
He's weak and he
caved to the woke
and that defined as presidency
and created the bad policies
that have led to
the bad results.
- So the guy that you
worked for, George W. Bush,
he was known as a guy
that would make a flub
every now and again or
say a phrase slightly odd.
But when you see
Biden doing it now,
you must be like, man, I
wish my guy would've got
the long leash that
they're giving this guy.
- Yeah, George Bush used to
joke that he had some issues
with the English language.
I think they call it
the American language
but it was always convivial
and he had inarticulate moments
but I don't think
anybody questions his
leadership strength
or his decision making or
the toughness of his policies
or his integrity and
that was a difference.
- Are you still in touch with,
I assume you're still in
touch with President Bush.
And are you surprised that
he went so apolitical?
I mean, I know most presidents
do but he really has just,
he enjoys painting it seems like
and living on the ranch
and just doesn't have much to
do with public policy anymore.
- You know, one of
the things about him,
he always understood
that he was gonna go in
and get out himself.
Now I remember during
the recount in 2000
when Al Gore was
working the phones
and trying to influence votes
in Florida during the recount,
George Bush was at
his ranch cutting wood
and people thought
he was disengaged.
He wasn't disengaged,
he always had this
healthy sense of removal.
He would go back to
the mansion at night
with his briefing book for
the next day and watch ESPN.
You know, I do think he
just had a healthy sense
of who he was, criticism
would roll off his back.
He was a strong leader
who made big decisions
but he didn't sweat the typical
Washington insider nonsense.
And I think that kept
him a lot better in touch
with the country.
- I'd like to finish
up with something else
because I've wanted to have
you on for quite some time
and we were trying to
get you on last year
for the 9/11 anniversary
and you usually on 9/11,
you do a full Twitter recap
of what that day was like
and being with the President
and everything else.
I lived in New York
City at the time,
much of my family lived in
New York City at the time.
And I remember you, I
remember obviously George Bush
and I remember Rudy Giuliani
and all of those things,
all of those people.
Can you just talk a
little bit about that
and maybe I can get you
back on in a couple weeks
in September to do a
bigger dive on that
but I just think it's
important to talk about.
- Yeah, you know Dave,
when I look back the thing
that strikes me having been
at the President's side
for much of that day and
being on board Air Force One
was how unemotional
it was for those of us
with the president which is I
think in many ways remarkable
'cause it was probably
the most emotional day
anybody alive today has had.
And it had to be that way.
You know, everybody, the
President was kinda just steely
like this, the secret service
around him, steely like that,
the military like that,
it was such a seriousness,
a steadiness.
And I was at the
President's side
when he said to the vice
president, we at war.
And he called the
secretary of defense
and said to the secretary
of defense, were at war
and it just sent a
chill down my spine.
And looking back,
some people might say,
well, of course, we're
at war, we were attacked.
Well, the next day
in the cabinet room,
when the president
held the meeting
with congressional leaders,
all of whom were
tremendously supportive.
One leader said to the
President, the Democrat,
I urge you to use
caution in your rhetoric,
war is such a scary word.
And I just remember
thinking to myself,
if this isn't war, what is?
The decision of the
President to tell people
that we're at war sent
the direction to everyone
to start planning for
what we were going to do.
And that was the right
and necessary step to take
and it reoriented everything
we've done since then.
It put us on a much stronger
ground against terrorism,
it's one of the reasons
we haven't been hit again
in a major attack.
It influenced our thinking
about growing strikes abroad
which have been carried out
now not only by George Bush
but by Barack Obama,
Donald Trump and Joe Biden.
It created a bipartisan template
for how to protect this country,
all of which came from
the strength I think
that he exhibited that day
but it was a time of the,
just the utmost seriousness,
the utmost weight
on our shoulders.
We were told by the CIA,
it's not a question of if,
it's a question of when
the second wave will be
and that permeated
all our thinking.
- Let's finish up
flash forwarding now
21 years into 2022.
And as a conservative
and as a media I guess,
a media watchdog or
is that a fair phrase?
You're a media watchdog
at this point, I guess.
What do you want to happen
with the Republicans right now?
I mean, obviously
everyone's talking about
this Trump DeSantis situation.
As a new Floridian, I
obviously love my governor
and he's partly
why I moved here.
I think there's
reasons to back Trump,
I think the machine
and he's willing to do
all the stuff to fight it.
What do you think
should happen here?
I mean, do you want
a robust primary?
Do you want one of them
to just get outta the way?
Is it somebody else?
What's your thought?
Well, one, I hope the
president does not declare
prior to the November election.
This election right
now, random on Joe Biden
and the Democrats
are losing it badly.
If it becomes a choice between
Joe Biden and Donald Trump
in indirect fashion, it's
only gonna help the Democrats.
Look into the future, I
think there are three issues
for President Trump.
One is, he'll be 78 in 2024.
Is he healthy enough
to be a president
at the age of 78 to 82?
Two, is what do the polls show
about his potential
democratic opponents
and how much are they
beating Joe Biden
or Kamala Harris or
Pete Buttigieg by?
If they're beating those
guys by more than Trump,
it's an important sign
that Donald Trump,
for all his strengths
and weaknesses
may not be our
strongest candidate.
Or maybe he is our
strongest candidate
that's why those polls
will be important.
And primary voters will
pay attention to it.
Three, how many people are
running against President Trump?
If it's one or two,
President Trump is be
in for a fair fight.
If it's three, four, five,
President Trump will win
with the largest plurality.
So as a analyst, those
are the three things
that I'm looking at.
The President's health, the
polls against the Democrats
and the number of Rs who
run against Donald Trump.
That will determine whether
Donald Trump wins or loses
potentially a primary
for presidency.
- By the way, to wrap this
up in a nice little bow,
have you seen the way
the media's been treating
DeSantis lately where
these big headlines
are basically saying he's
Trump but he's even worse
because he's competent.
That's the new move
that they were gonna treat
anyone like this, right?
He's got all the bad stuff
of Trump plus he's competent,
that's double Hitler
or something like that.
- Which takes me
right back to my book.
When I wrote "Suppression,
Deception, Snobbery, and Bias"
because I knew the press
did it to Donald Trump
and I blew the whistle on it.
But as we talked earlier,
they're going to do it
to the next Republican too
because they're activists
for a cause and they're not
neutral, they're not objective.
They're not serving our
country when they do that.
And they will do it to DeSantis.
They'll do it to
whoever our nominee is
and it doesn't matter if the
Democrat is Biden, Harris,
you name who, they're
gonna do it again.
- Ari, I've enjoyed
talking to you.
The book is great, we're gonna
link to it right down below.
And can you stick around
for one more thing,
we're gonna throw in
our locals community.
- Yes, I can.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.